one of the first stories of I'm ever
coming to LA I saw a very famous comic
who I loved and I yelled his name out
like that and he went [ __ ] you and I was
like holy [ __ ] now I've had a encounter
with him since but you nights just
premiered at the Toronto Film Festival
he saw the movie wanted to come and meet
me oh it's so nice to meet you you know
I'm a big fan I saw them I said we've
met before briefly but we met
basket ball knives was the second film I
had acted in I was directed by the late
great Scott Calvert who had directed all
my music videos and was really
encouraging me to become an actor
something I wasn't interested at the
time but thankfully with his persuasion
and also Penny Marshall I ended up
finding movies and acting and I'm never
wanting to do anything else I played a
very angry and violent heroin addict /
high school basketball player that was
probably the movie that I worked the
hardest to get the part I had auditioned
probably about seven times my audition
became something of a thing for people
to actually come in and watch live and
then finally once me and Leo were able
to get in the room together everybody
agreed that I was the right guy for the
part probably the most memorable for me
was the scene when the guy rips us off
and we've chased him down and then
finally catch him on the roof I was
running and jumping over a different
stuff and jump over the giant row of
trash bags and one take my foot caught
the edge of it and went to put my arms
up to stop my fall and separated my
shoulder you still finished the rest of
the scene and then I was in a New Jersey
hospital at 7 o'clock in the morning
fear was also a movie that I was not
supposed to be in or get the part
I had Renaissance man and Basketball
Diaries in the can but neither one of
them come out yet and Leo had actually
mentioned to James Foley that he should
look at me for this part James Foley
didn't know who I was and then when Leo
said Marky Mark and then Jamie thought
it was a joke and kind of laughed he
said no you should really meet him I
think he'd be great in this part I just
worked with him so I had a meeting with
Jamie we had an eight-hour meeting had
lunch went to a bar and then by the time
I got to my house my phone was ringing
and it was him and he was like dude I
just want to let you know I mean there's
no way you can have this part but I
really had a good time with that hope we
can still be friends I said dude I
wouldn't have hung out with you for more
than you know the ceremonial hour if I
didn't have a good time with you too
it's all good and then he kind of felt
bad and was like well maybe I can
audition you for one of the guys in the
gang but the other guys in the gang
didn't have enough lines to really even
audition for so I was reading the part
of David McCall but to play one of the
other parts and then after my audition
he had actually gone to the studio and
said if you don't hire more Paul Berg in
the lead of this movie then I'm not
gonna do the movie every day was it was
a blast you know working with Reece and
and Bill Peterson and Amy and everybody
but the funny thing that happened was
you know I like to improvise and so when
I was screaming at the I think you know
the people he put it in the gag reel and
when everybody saw the gag reel you know
they really responded to that moment
should have allowed nature to take its
course in the end it will anyway but
then when Brian Grazer saw the movie
that wasn't in the movie and Brian goes
hey what happened to that thing as the
people is like one of my favorite parts
he goes oh no that was Mark was just
joking around he said well you got to
have that in the movie and Jamie was a
little reluctant but it's more than the
more memorable moments in the film
oh but boogie nights it was different
because there's been a few movies in my
career that are like really hard to
pitch on the spot and that was
definitely one of them you know I wasn't
really interested in going into the
world of pornography and all that stuff
and you know because I'd done the Calvin
Klein thing I didn't know anything about
Paul Thomas Anderson so I didn't know
what why he would want me for this
particular movie I kept hearing about it
and then I finally said okay I'll read
it I read the first 30 pages I put it
down and so let me just meet Paul and
kind of see where his head's at I had a
meeting with him hit it off he said all
right I want you to play the part but
again I don't think he was a hundred
percent sure because he was like let's
just have a meeting with some of the
other guys so it was me john c reilly
Philip Seymour Hoffman God rest his soul
and Thomas Jane and then you know Paul
pulled out the scripts and then we all
started reading and improvising and
doing that whole thing and I think
that's when he was really comfortable
with me having the part probably the
most difficult to shoot and just yeah
when painting was this scene without
four Molina with the firecrackers and we
were just in this room for such a long
time and it was with the firecrackers
and the intensity and all that
[Music]
black guy has a gun on his jacket
[Music]
[Applause]
no all the scenes I mean the scene the
big blow I love the big blow up scene
with me and Bert in the backyard and all
the stuff in the studio with Michael pen
I mean there was a you know great great
great moments and experiences know
would three kings I got a call to meet
with with David O'Russell the same agent
who represented James Gray who I did the
yards and we own the night with also
represented Paul Thomas Anderson why did
Boogie Nights with and represented David
O'Russell so it was one of those things
where he said hey you know you should
really meet David loved flirting with
disaster and spanking the monkey but I
was really method back then so I was
still in the whole yards headspace and
he just kept remembering it was like did
we and I wanted you for the part but
then I didn't know because you you were
like this other part and I don't know if
that's how you were in real life and so
we talked about the park quite a bit and
then he wanted Spike Jones who hadn't
really acted in a film before and the
studio was was giving a little push back
so we had an opportunity to then kind of
work on a lot of the scenes and put
spike in me on tape and so I think
that's where David felt more comfortable
hiring me it was kind of like a bit of a
secret audition even though he was like
kind of offering me the part he wanted
to make sure that I wasn't Leo handler
from the yards which was a very
different character Spike Jones was
great I mean we had a lot of fun Spike's
a gamer he likes to try things and I was
a fantastic filmmaker
and it's alright but a wonderful actor
as well
and with a perfect storm actually
because of three kings I was offered the
part love to absolutely love Wolfgang
Peterson all of his movies especially
dusk food and I thought you know it was
an honor to be able to play a real
person you know who would kind of go out
there and and be brave enough to go on a
sword boat and you know somebody who was
from back home and I knew I had a
responsibility to make his family proud
spent a lot of time living in the crow's
nest hanging with his brother and his
mom and the family and going out on real
boats and doing all that stuff it was it
was an awesome experience during that
movie I had been introduced to sushi
from David O'Russell and Chuck Rovin and
they want to have dinner normally I'm
pretty picky about where we're going but
I just said okay and they were picking
the place and they're sure tomate seats
and I'm like what is this dude and I'm
like oh so she don't worry you love it
I'm not eating [ __ ] then I finally start
tasting and trying stuff ate everything
that came out absolutely fell in love
with it and then would literally because
there were so many technical glitches
with making that movie with the gimbal
and the tank and the effects and that I
would have sometimes like days on end
where we'd never go in front of camera
would just be sitting in our trailer so
fly all the way across town back to my
seat like every day so I just assumed
that every sushi place was the same
quality so when we went down to Dana
Point
- now go shoot out on the water I went
to a sushi place the night before got
like violently ill and then I still had
to go out on the boat the next day and
we were in like 25 30 foot swells
literally in between lines I was puking
and almost projectile vomiting on George
was not a good time
the only reason for for making Planet of
the Apes was to work with Tim Burton and
and dick zanuck you know was never
really a huge fan of the original and
not really into sci-fi but I wanted an
opportunity to work with Tim so I just
jumped at it you know at that stage of
my career I still felt like I'd be far
more beneficial for me to work with
really successful directors and there
would be so much for me to learn and
benefit from yeah Tim was absolutely
awesome I think the thing that we both
experienced together is let's not have a
start date without having a complete
script you know what a big movie like
that in a tentpole you know they have a
tendency to say okay this movie has to
be out by this particular time and you
know Tim's an artist so he doesn't want
to be rushed and he wants to make sure
the things are gonna be perfect doesn't
want to compromise what he wants to do
or how he wants to do it you know that
was one of the things I learned but also
I just get I love to hang out with him
and he's such a sweet guy when we were
doing additional shooting in London or
we were working in Paris I was in Paris
and he would come and we were doing ADR
and stuff like that we'd go out and you
know we go to dinner or go for drinks
and he would sit there just drawing
people and you know I was always trying
to get my hands on his drawings
I Heart Huckabees was the second film
that I'd done with David you know it was
just awesome working with him I mean he
was he was really trying to do something
special and unique and would send me off
he knows that I was a bit method about
like things to be able to research and
prepare and he would have me listen to
it when with Herman's dad and a jewel
tree and all these different
philosophies of our life and everything
and it was for me it was an awesome
experience my daughter was born during
the filming and we were just off doing
our thing had a great time I think
working with Dustin and Jason and Lilly
and Isabel and Naomi and Jude it was uh
it was a lot of fun and also I met
Geron that movie and uh gosh Jonah Hill
did his first scene when he was at the
dinner table what happens in the meadow
vibrating everything everything it's
beautiful beautiful also Richard Jenkins
gene smart there were so many amazing
people on that movie it was such a great
experience
The Departed was interesting it was it
was one of those things where I wasn't
committed to making the movie but my
agent told Marty that I was some already
called me a black and like he was all
excited about us making this movie
together and I said I'm not doing the
movie you know I wanted a different part
and I wanted some other different things
and and we had been talking about doing
it for a long time and then things just
happened in the studio push back on
certain things and so I said no I don't
want to do it and then Marty was just
like silent for a minute and then I said
okay and hung up and then my agent
called me back you know like five
minutes later it was like what the [ __ ]
just go talk to him so they sent me a
plane on the weekend I was off in
Toronto went to Marty's office I had
read the script again and at this time I
was pretty angry I was like nah I'm not
doing he was but look at this part look
what you get to do with all these people
and you know he knows I'm from that
world and I said talk to him about
improvising and doing my thing and he
said dude free to do what you want to do
well the fighter was one of those ones
we was like just constantly an uphill
battle to get made the movie I think was
originally supposed to be made in 2006
there have been number of directors on
the project Darren Aronofsky was one
Brad Pitt at one point was attached than
that Damon and movie just kept falling
apart I had already committed to the
movie and training and all that stuff I
remember reading the script the first
time and I was like I just started
getting crazy and I was like okay this
is the movie I wanted to do a boxing
movie before with Robert De Niro where
he was gonna play Angelo Dundee and I
was playing the fighter from East Boston
named Vinny Curto and that movie fell
apart and I was determined to kind of
like do my boxing movie so when the
fighter came I was just like okay I just
started training and I never stopped but
the movie kept falling apart then we
would find another director and finally
I just went to the studio and I was like
guys you got to let me do this you know
pull the movie out I'll finance it it
was a bit of an uphill battle to get the
director that I wanted but David and I
had such a great relationship every time
we were talking to another director or
kind of going down the road with
somebody else he just called me and we
just start talking about the movie and I
was like wow I don't think they're gonna
go for it but I'll take this idea and
I'll run with it and I'll add it to the
script I just got to the point words
she's sitting and I remember
sitting in my old house in my bathroom
on this little Shea's lounge in there
and we just sit on the phone and talk
forever and then I said you know I got
to make this happen so I wrote this long
letter and I was going to the head of
the studio I want to talk about all the
reasons why I wanted David O to make
this movie and why they should have
trust in me to allow me to kind of go
with my gut and finally you know I got
everybody to agree and David was able to
show everybody what what kind of talent
he has it was one of those things I
promise Micky Ward I was going to get
the movie made promise Dicky
I promised Alice and I also I wanted to
show people that Lowell got a really bad
rap Lowell is one of the great
industrial towns of America and just
because of the documentary high on crack
Street
it gave Lowell a very bad reputation you
know
Lowell is a great great great place and
it was it was important for me to get it
done
well the thing about Ted it's very
similar to boogie nice it's extremely
difficult movie to pitch I mean you know
as soon as somebody says a guy in a
teddy bear you know buddy they smoke
weed and I'm like no no no not happening
my agent also represented sets I'm
thinking okay well he's just jamming me
on on a movie for another client but I
started hearing from other people at
other agencies and they were like no no
no you got to read this thing is really
cool so I read it kind of forget that
you know you're talking about a teddy
bears just like this great buddy comedy
so I met with Seth really hit it off
with him saw the the kind of test of the
bear which looked cool and believable
and real and then went and made the
movie
it's the largest highest-grossing hour
comedy of all time and it was one of
those things where he just had to take a
swing you know have faith in what we're
doing and really commit you know my
favorite scene in the movie there's many
but uh certainly the white-trash names
cuz I thought it was one of those things
while I'm here I am having to learn 50
names that really connect to nothing I
just didn't think it would be in the
movie so I said to Seth I was like well
what if we kind of do it like we and I'm
always play these games and I could just
spit him off rapid-fire Mickey Kelsey
Sean and Jolene early Claudia Savannah
Casey Dolly Kendrick Holly Chloe Devin
Emily [ __ ] Becky no wait was it any
one of those names with Al in after it
yes oh I got you [ __ ] I got you
okay
Brandi Lynn heaven Jamie Lynn [ __ ] so
was one of those things that ended up
being really cool
I have to talk about the other guys just
because it's my first comedy I wanted to
do comedy for a long time you know there
are comedic elements and performances
that I've done but never done a
full-blown comedy I did the kind of
scene with Steve Carell and Tina Fey and
date night but that was just a little
thing to kind of get my feet wet
I met with a lot of comics and I was
like I don't know when I met Will
Ferrell and Adam McKay everything
changed these guys were just so cool so
sweet so funny with two minutes into the
dinner I was like I'm in there like we
haven't even told you the story yet I
said I don't give a [ __ ] whatever you
want to do I'll do it with you guys and
they're like okay well can we tell you
the story I was sure and then we did
they told me the story of these two cops
and I was just laughing hysterically and
then literally three months later I get
a script and then another three months
we're on the set we're shooting and I
was a little shy at first and that I
loved to improvise but you know I mean
they were encouraging me to get really
crazy so I said dude once I get crazy
crazy it's like hard to stop me and I
didn't want to like rub people the wrong
way right but they never told me to stop
they always encouraged me to do more and
try more every scene I was we went crazy
I mean the stuff with Will and I arguing
about a lion and the tuna I mean me
throwing hot coffee on Melissa but the
scene that I think they thought I was
going they didn't know where I was going
with it was the scene with with Eva
Mendes I'm like who's that who are you
I'm dr. Sheila gamble his wife come on
seriously who is that his old lady
sweetie it's a work station you come in
here dressed like a hobo
it's distracting I know you're working
I'm so sorry come on seriously come on
what who is that and I just keep trying
to talk to her and and we'll just keep
trying to talk to me and then I keep
like going back and trying to hug her
and kiss her and all that stuff those
are the scenes that they thought I was
going a little bit too far but I think
those were the ones that were because it
was just this whole obsession of a like
how does this kind of get this girl you
know there's no [ __ ] way but um great
great time loved working with those guys
I mean everybody was involved in that
movie even Dewayne and Sam I remember
the first time that Sam yelled at will I
mean we'll genuinely got so scared but
oh it was so funny
yeah mile 22 was cool it's one of those
things repeating our making a movie we
made three movies all true stories all
about kind of like tragic situations and
having to deal with that the first idea
was let's just do something different
that we don't have to like walk so
gingerly let's have some fun do
something crazy and then I originally I
was just gonna play the kind of like the
bad guy was gonna be in the movie like
two and a half weeks and then involved
to kind of being silver story over time
but yeah it's a lot of fun it was
amazing kind of learning about this
world that a lot of people don't know
exists and these people that that do
some pretty shady stuff to protect our
country and they're out there and they
don't get the kind of parades and the
Welcome homes but you know branch of the
CIA these are the guys that go out there
and really get their hands dirty and in
a situation where you have an uprising
or something like that in a third-world
country
he kind of has no rules and he'll decide
who lives and dies and what happens in
between it was a lot of fun talking
about the different roles the kind of
kind of looking back at my career I've
always just tried to take it one part at
the time coming from music and trying to
pivot into acting was not something that
a lot of people were successful at and
you know for me it was definitely a
marathon not a sprint I get at it like I
just started better like and I feel like
you know what if I keep doing the right
thing and working hard I can have a
career in this business that's how I
look at it
you